some New York City schools are going to
the dogs in the best possible way a
program using comfort dogs teaches
resiliency as well as social and
emotional skills the curriculum called
mud agrees was developed by Yale
University in New York's North Shore
Animal League the city's Department of
Education expanded the program to 42
schools this year bianna golodryga went
to an elementary school in Brooklyn
where the teacher's pet might actually
sleep in class does sleep in class and I
think I could sell James on this story
it's a good one here's how New York
City's comfort dog program works
each school adopts rescue animals which
live with a school administrator during
the day these cuddly pups are embedded
in school life they do everything from
curbing conflict to motivating students
to offering some puppy love I like dogs
and sharks they always make me happy
every morning principal Kevin bulls
walks brightly from his home to new
bridges Elementary School in Brooklyn
there are teachers who have explicitly
said I love brightly so much because she
reminds me of the students we have to
care about the most brightly is the more
rambunctious of the two rescue dogs
turned comfort canines who have
transformed the learning experience for
students like 3rd grader
Akeelah allen do they make me feel
better of these nonhumans Cheyne is the
calmer mellower dog have a great day
okay she greets students in the morning
attend school assemblies many times and
serves as a reading buddy and shine we
call the elder statesman of the tube but
she'll just snuggle up next to on the
carpet in the classroom and you could
read to her for hours so they each bring
a little different personality to the
mix these furry four-legged friends and
others like them started roaming school
halls at the suggestion of a student
council a fifth grader told a New York
City official that students were angry
for no reason and that dogs could help
okay the way for principal Bowles the
pets are a weight
bolster culture and community at his
school were there any push backs at all
from either parents students or teachers
to the idea there was some nervousness
at the beginning about things like
allergies and then some of the kids who
were actually afraid of dogs have come
to love the dogs fifth grader Tyreese
Butz remembers what class was like
without these bushy-tailed companions
fourth grade was kind of weird because
all the kids were mean and not following
directions everybody came to fifth grade
and shine umbrellas here
the oldest acted different and started
being happy and being nice to each other
do you get to play more with the dogs
when you behave mm-hmm we have some
really challenging behaviors at our
school as every school does and seeing
certain students who now have
individualized behavior plans where if
they meet certain goals each day they
get to come and see me and spend time
with the dog has brought a real sense of
purpose to those students days in which
they spend the morning trying to earn
time with the dog and then after they
spend time with the dog they are calm
and positive for the rest of the day it
incentivizes them exactly that happened
to you before
the dogs teach kids about responsibility
empathy and making connections across
New York City 95% of participating
educators say the canines have reduced
emotional distress among students shine
and brightly possess the qualities
inherent in the best social workers
warmth and unconditional love
shaped trade Jonna Windley a fifth
grader helps train the dogs after school
that's a nice feeling right yes and it
goes both ways a preliminary evaluation
of the program conducted by Yale
University reveals that 90% of
participating educators reported
improved student behavior 79% said the
dogs increased student interest in
school and the researchers are hopeful
that this success might one day be
reflected in academic achievement and
guys.i
know who was happier to see each other
the dogs or the kids when they'd walk
into the room I think about him saying
how stressed are these 7 year olds which
which which is what I thought too but
how stressful but I didn't think about
the anger at about that the kids have
and how the dogs can yeah they have
rough home lives
yes something they look forward to who's
on pootie duty yeah yeah that's a
different segment whole nother story
thank you be on L said